the church of what's happening now is
presented by on it
this show is brought to you by zip
recruiter
posting your job in one place isn't
enough to find quality candidates
lucky for you and and thankfully to
ziprecruiter.com there's a better way
our listeners can post their job to over
200 plus job sites including social
media and they can try it for free when
they go to ziprecruiter.com
church it's ziprecruiter.com
church
this show is also brought to you by
helix sleep helix sleep is the website
where you can buy mattresses online
customized for you for hundreds of
dollars instead of thousands
go to helixsleep.com joey right now to
get 50 off of your order that's
helixsleep.com
joey
kick that mutely kick it we ain't got
time to dilly daddle
oh [ __ ]
coming at you
oh [ __ ]
here we
church
go
what's happened now
chris porter
lee syed
here you go [ __ ]
you're feeling a little depressed you're
down
you're [ __ ] you stepped on your cat
it's over
it's a new day [ __ ]
here we go
if you're not ready to turn this [ __ ]
up as a human being
this part right here
don't even [ __ ] talk to me no more
right here here we go
here we go
this [ __ ] is still amazing still amazing
let's go rob a liquor store no this is
it this is it this is
if you're autistic right now you just
jump out of the window yeah this [ __ ]
here you go
church of what's happened now it's like
listening to
for me it's like listening to
three different bands in one like i
could hear a little aerosmith in there
yep
you definitely could hear their
distinctive sound but there's some other
piece in there there's that zeppelin
that
is that well anytime i hear a heavy
metal you got to go straight down to
zeppelin yeah yeah
just that guitar and that
that anger
is just that's all zeppelin it sounds
like i like slash had like a certain
bravado like this oh yeah he did his
tone is amazing is amazing it's weird
that that's what they say like as soon
as you hear the first three chords
you should know who exactly it is if
you're into that type of stuff like
gilmore from pink floyd yeah classically
clapton has a
distinctive tone
obviously hendrix that's why these guys
or where the [ __ ] they are
because they're a lot similar
but they all have their distinctive the
same thing with comics
you know i said this years ago that
comedians are we're all funny yeah we're
all funny
it's the backstory and everything else
that'll round this out once you get the
[ __ ] know the hell we are like
anything else in life
being funny i mean
not to be egotistical but it's it's
pretty easy like everyone's funny like
uber drivers are funny
you know my lyft driver the whole way
here told me how funny everyone thinks
he is you know
but it takes you know it's a different
thing to
do what we do
well we have to channel it in a certain
way and that's where the mistake is like
and we've been to a thousand open mics
and over the years
as a uh
marketing strategy a lot of clubs that
said you know new talent office night
and or the whole office comes to the
[ __ ] club you know 60 people to watch
the funny guy by the cooler go on stage
and it's a complete different game it's
like trying to be it's like watching the
ufc and going you know what i'm gonna go
down to the 7-eleven and pick a fight
one of those homeless guys
and i'm gonna [ __ ] hit him with an
elbow and a [ __ ] kick to the leg yeah
this guy went to vietnam yeah he'll kill
you with popcorn and he has nothing to
live for nothing to live for it's so
people sometimes think it's that easy
that's
the only thing that's bothered me about
young comics over the years
never like about 10 years ago i had a
guy who
had all the answers
you know he had done comedy twice and he
got invited to a montreal showcase
you thought this [ __ ] guy was jerry
lewis
yeah yeah he was at the store like
harassing comments like how long did it
take you to be up here six years i did
it in [ __ ] three nights yeah how long
did it take you to find your voice oh my
god i already found it then i'll tell
you how lonely this guy got this guy was
[ __ ] crazy
he scheduled his benefit and he told
everybody all these celebrities are
going to be there
it was just a lie yeah to sell tickets i
mean he had been
this guy told me he called ben affleck's
mother
he got a hold of her number and called
her in boston
to ask her if ben could be there he told
christina this is
you know 12 years ago
ben affleck was really hot and he was
young and [ __ ] and jennifer lopez and
him and matt damon were still hanging
out
yeah they were still hanging out and
then he bombed there yeah and then
nobody would book him around town so
this [ __ ] momo bought a restaurant in
the valley
and put a patio out there on wednesday
nights he only wanted clean comedy he
thought everybody else is not really a
comedian he told me to my face
dirty comedians people who talk about
that type of topics and not really
comics yeah okay
okay ask me what where the restaurant is
today yeah done [ __ ] him with this clean
[ __ ] comedy on a [ __ ]
balcony you [ __ ] [ __ ]
in this day and age and he had the same
clean comics up there every week
like and i just watched him die i never
offered nothing i never said nothing i
just sat in the sidelines and watched
him die a slope that
i'd see him and he'd tell me how packed
it was
who was up there the celebrities that
would go to his restaurant i'd ask
people
and they go dog
there's nobody there
it's always [ __ ] empty on wednesday
so i don't get that the people i don't
get that [ __ ] either how do you lie like
that when it's hot when it's easily
provable
like there were other people there dude
i don't get it i'll tell you what and
stanhope told me this one time he goes
does doesn't it burn you up
when you get to a club and it's empty
and then like last week
we had to [ __ ] get you know we had a
light people on fire to get them away
from the door yeah you know but this
week that rodeo is killing us and you're
like what the [ __ ] are you talking about
i just can't sell no tickets just tell
me the truth why are you blowing smoke
up my [ __ ] ass and [ __ ] you know i
can't give away a [ __ ] ticket
although to be fair
some of some cities man it's like i've
been to des moines twice when the state
fair was there
and you you can't
you kevin hart could be there he's not
selling a ticket are you serious yeah
man
i you know people have different
priorities in different areas and you
know the state fair only comes around
once a year
and the funny bones open every week
you know
that's crazy yeah
you can't pull them from the state fair
they're over there eating poison
you even go to a state fair you see the
food they give you there oh dude they
they a hamburger where the bun is a
krispy kreme doughnut
it's [ __ ] great there's one play you
know you ever watch those
shows and they show you like uh you know
like places to eat yeah during like uh
you know in those small to cities i bet
they have one or two great places
that this the thing but the rest is corn
dogs and [ __ ]
that [ __ ] yeah but that's what you go to
the that's the first yeah yeah that's
get a funnel cake where else do you get
a funnel cake jesus i had one at this
place
about five years ago they do a carnival
down the corner here yeah yeah before
the baby i took my wife on a date down
there let's go to the corner yes i
walked in every gang affiliation was
there
we ate a funnel cake through took three
hook shots at the basket we got the [ __ ]
out of it
[Laughter]
it's like magic mountain except south i
would never ever go on one of those
[ __ ] [ __ ] up carnival rides or let
my child go on one of those things i
went on one and the carney
i i think that's the appropriate term
thought he'd be cool because there was
no one in line that he'd just let the
ride go for a while and it was like one
of those crazy octopus ones
there's a reason that shit's only 60
seconds because after about two and a
half minutes you're like get me the [ __ ]
off this thing i'm gonna throw up
and he let it go for like a good five
like to the point where people were on
the ride going please make this stop
it was
yeah that shit's not safe and those guys
again are don't have a whole lot to live
for
you know [ __ ] carnival people
like when you can be at your ticket
booth holding a schlitz
like that's i mean als
you know that's kind of cool but also
yeah it's probably not good for osha
standards
i tell you people i know you're gonna
misunderstood when i said that i'm not
talking about bottom and bailey
carnivals
i'm talking about the ones that come to
your [ __ ] neighborhood and everybody
looks like they're ex-felons they're in
parking lots yeah yeah those things you
never have you never like in your drug
days even thought about going on like it
seems like the perfect place where [ __ ]
no that's a complete different level of
[ __ ] uh
filth
that's a complete different level i
dated a girl that was a carnival thing
she gave me a rash for [ __ ] four
years
that [ __ ] never goes away those rashes
those [ __ ] carnival chicks can get
those
rashes like in michigan
and you dated her for four years i dated
for the weekend you know thursday
through sunday we feel like
stuck around for four years yeah we
broke up on sunday like usual
relationships on the road out
you meet him on thursday you give him a
faithful daisy ring on saturday night
and on sunday i'll call you when i get
you you gave him a fake you gave him a
ring i used to buy like 10 of them on
sale [ __ ] oh [ __ ] those are you're a
much better gentleman than i ever was
you got to close them i'm not a good
looking dude but you bust out the rock
when they're all rocked up with a couple
of cocktails that's that always closes
really sure you give them a cuban
zirconia they don't [ __ ] know see i
was always freaked out i was always the
guy that was like listen you know i
leave on sunday and
you know this is gonna like and then i'd
just be like this is gonna be over in
two days so
if you're cool with that cool but
otherwise
i'm not
i just dated so many crazy chicks on the
road you mean [ __ ] the craziest one i
ever met was in syracuse
this one actually called my manager at
the time no way yeah it was bad
it was bad and it started as a job like
i just went to work for her and i would
go up there and she'd go where do you
stay when you were at a hotel you should
stay downstairs
and that's when it started and i don't
have to even go into this story yeah
yeah yeah i might go to the east coast
i'd go over there and i'm she had a
landscape company and i'd work for her
how often did you propose to this woman
it's not that one you don't have to post
i just moved a couple rocks she was in
yeah yeah she was cooking
i can't believe you would propose like
no there was a time when i was [ __ ]
nuts okay
like 98 i went on the road it was
[ __ ] you know how would you explain
that i was doing yoda runs
those and you're in michigan the whole
week
yeah they don't give you a dime for
[ __ ] a hotel and then you would work
like uh
he would throw you into shitty rooms at
first yeah yeah i got attacked by
pelicans at one of those [ __ ]
michigan cities with two hot dogs in my
hand
you know
the place was a [ __ ] uh
the guy owned both of them
it was by bay city the one club saginaw
okay and he had another one in another
town and i did him both yeah and he had
theaters and basically you paid for your
hotel room and on saturday you gave him
the receipt and he paid you to the penny
real like if it was 67 and 32 he'd give
you 67 32 for your time
he wore a wig
there was never more than 20 people in
that room
but he said he had a theater and he goes
i got nothing else to do i'm retired i
own the property yeah he goes what do i
care you know even if i lose money it's
a tax write-off or something it was like
yeah i refused to go back up and then he
had another
dumpy theater that was like where people
used to whack off when they turned it
into a comedy room oh okay like he had
one of those places but he didn't tell
the regulars no he mopped the floor no
it still had that sticky little stinky
sperm spell in the air and they never
opened the windows and shits oh it was
[ __ ] disgusting oh yeah it was where
the [ __ ] was mount something mount
something michigan dude i did one
trivial or no i don't even think i did
it i think i was booked for it and i had
got booked for something
respectable
and i [ __ ] passed it off to my
friends and they ended up having like
the worst time they've ever had
well to be and it wasn't tribble's fault
my buddy decided he needed to pee
they pulled over their car got stuck in
the snow they got their car unstuck
got back on the highway realized dude
never peed
so they just pulled over to get stuck
basically for people at home
saying what the [ __ ] the triple run
or yoda run they're the entry-level runs
you make when you get into comedy and
let me tell you something they're very
helpful
i feel that if you don't do them you're
missing out on a big part of your career
because
this is the book yeah remember that's
your book that is you everybody likes a
book this is your book
your book isn't going to be when you
marry the chick from that show and
you're successful there's no story there
yeah
you got a [ __ ] nanny and
people offer you water and you're funny
that that's not the the story
the story is when you go on a triple run
and you start it with 10 bucks yeah and
you make it [ __ ] work like you got
three quarters of a tank of gas you
already went on that and guys you guys
got google and you could type it in it
tells you how many miles we had to have
the notebook we had the atlas the atlas
with the [ __ ] pencil yeah to do the
whole route and no no no no no please
you know how many times i got lost in
this great country of ours do you have
any [ __ ] idea how many times i got
lost and guys that's the story
all this other [ __ ] out here that you
hear is talking about this is [ __ ]
when you do those triple runs and you go
out on two of them you hate yourself
but when you go back to your local club
that tuesday people are like what
happened to you
i just went to hell yeah two weeks you
know and he'd send you the the sheets
and on the sheets he would say watch
your language these rumors are mormon
watch your language these rumors of
mormon watch your language these rooms a
moment one would say
this club is active if something gets
thrown at you run away and go to your
room like it was [ __ ] nuts like that
was the itinerary and it was like you
wake up
you get in your car monday the first gig
is always what 24 hours away it was like
the blues brothers yeah that's that's
what it is that's exactly what it is
except not the end part where you get
the coolest concert with cam calloway
but it's so weird how all those weekends
in retrospect
no matter how hard they were they always
worked out
even if you broke even
somebody would say hey what are you
doing tomorrow man i got front row for
the dallas cowboys against the giants
and you're like i'm going to a game with
six bucks in my pocket but i'm sitting
in the front row like that's and it
makes you appreciate
that whole journey but also we remember
we now that we're so far away from we
only remember that those days but there
were there were plenty of weekends where
didn't [ __ ] happen you're like what the
[ __ ] have i done with my life
at that time i gotta be honest with you
in my head
i could have been locked up oh i was
having
the best time of my life with no money
like i just survived on
subway sandwiches veggie and cheese yeah
yeah from tuesday on the because you're
out there what are you gonna do come all
the way [ __ ] home when you go out on
those things if you don't go out for
three weeks it's not worth your weight
and go yeah yeah so you got to go out
disappear for three weeks so on sunday
monday tuesday you're basically camping
when you're a feature act
you're camping you're at a you know you
save one night like you go you know what
i'll say 42.50 for a motel six the last
night yeah like a shower and watch tv
and driving to the club like a normal
human being
but for two nights you'll sleep at rest
stops and take showers in hotels and
jump in the pool like a [ __ ] savage
wash your balls and brush your teeth in
the pool i mean but
at the end of the day
it all worked out i guess you're right
yeah i was at an age i think at that
point i guess i'm looking at it now at
my age but at that point i was
i started comedy when i was 19.
yeah so i was 21-22 so yeah i guess i
was just happy to be out and about
i really do look at some of those gigs
that i did as a youngster and i'm just
like how happy were you when you got
three drink tickets tell them the truth
oh dude you were broke flat broke right
now you walk into a barn they go you the
feature here's three drink tickets
your heart would stop lee you got three
free drinks plus you're gonna get
another two for free from the bartender
if you do well yeah yeah or if you just
take care of them yeah give them 10
bucks yeah and everything works itself
out well the best was when it was like
food's on us
because then you're like well i got at
least one or two meals taken care of
because that that's your big experience
that's your big expense yeah just trying
to eat so every free meal is another
20 bucks for you to buy weed and there
was no free breakfast in those days at
the hotel yeah the hindu started that
they give you the free egg and [ __ ] with
the toast
remember the first time you went down
hindus were always cooking breakfast
like what the [ __ ] is this
and they were the nicest people in the
world they always had hard-boiled eggs i
remember eating them because at some
hotels they just have hard-boiled eggs
and white bread i would take white bread
toast it put butter all over and just
crack
hard-boiled eggs on and just eat like
four of those [ __ ] things because i
knew those next eight hours on the road
were going to be brutal
like the little things like that like
you prepared yourself for brutality yeah
would you ever go back to these gigs
again or were these all were all these
things like one times
i'd like to do it like
i would do it with joey like so we could
like have someone to remember it with
but i would still like
i would stay in a much nicer hotel than
i stayed oh my god i wouldn't stay in
the hotels but i'd do the [ __ ] gigs
again oh well i didn't even mean like
would you do them now i meant like would
you do them
like a couple years in a row would you
would you go on tour and be like oh i
was here last year at the same hotel oh
yeah oh yeah oh yeah
yeah i did those triple runs from 95
to
99 the last time i tr no i'm lying to
you guys 2 000.
i moved down here and i never did them
again and then they called my manager
because i got a co-headlining
yeah go ahead line dribble that's not
bad it was like 150 a show because he
paid 50 or 125 or 175.
i did that with the goofiest [ __ ]
comic
ever like one of those anti-la
you guys are all [ __ ] homos that live
in l.a you have to suck dick to be
successful
yeah they're going to call me i'm going
to make it on the road those [ __ ]
losers yeah like yeah the guy that's
working at radio shack yeah yeah
he was terrible and then
it was basically in it just to sell the
t-shirt after the show right the t-shirt
and that was his whole living was triple
runs yeah that's all he did he refused
he would say that those clubs are
commercialized they just didn't want to
hire him so in his head
he made up something to rationalize why
they didn't hire him yeah they're all
anti-commercial clubs connected to
comedy central and
he would i would look at him back then
and go you [ __ ] just [ __ ] so yeah
it was just four days in the car with
him he didn't smoke reefer yeah he was a
christian he had to get in the car
sunday and saturday night and
drive all night we drove all night he
dropped me off at some spokane
airport or something
and i [ __ ] got delayed in lax i still
remember like my plane was supposed to
land at two in the afternoon
i didn't come in till 11. the only good
thing was dean kane was at the airport i
was like [ __ ] superman
i'm doing the right thing i was on the
same plane with [ __ ] superman
you started when you were 19. that's
when i yeah this is my first home of
mike what made you go on stage i was
trying to meet chicks
flat out you got flat out i went to high
school no college no i went to college
for a year
and then
i hated it
and uh my buddy
who was one of those dudes that
he'd like watch a movie and wanted to
he'd be that movie like he saw swingers
dude and like a week later was like
wearing suits and swing dancing all of a
sudden i'm writing the script writing
script yeah calling me baby all of a
sudden
and uh so he saw i don't know it was a
punchline or the king of comedy or
whatever but one of those
older how does the punch punchline push
me over the top so that dude called you
know this was 98 so still yellow pages
time so he opened up the phone book to
comedy clubs in kansas city and there
was one and he called him and goes how
do i become a stand-up comic
and they the girl kind of laughed and he
was like she was like i got we got an
open mic on mondays come down and sign
up
and he called me and he told me all
about it
and i you know it was kind of intriguing
and then a month later or you know like
a week later i went and saw him do it
and i was like i'm funnier like half
these dudes
at least
and uh
then about about a month later i got the
balls to do it and uh then
i don't think i missed an open mic for a
year
and then the only reason i missed one
was because i had started a new job and
i had to train but
yeah just got straight into it and then
she's been doing comedy 19 years yeah
and by the time i was uh
24 i was it was my job
and you were based out of kansas city at
the time based out of kansas city what
clubs are you working at the time out of
kansas city as a feature act um
you know this is very early onset of the
improvs and you know tampa had just
opened
um doing a lot of those runs doing
you know the old
the old omaha funny bone
all those places just anywhere i could
fort wayne snickers you know driving
around with some hack
headliner that told me he was funnier
than me and then wasn't and then asked
me to drive around fort wayne looking
for crack i remember the green bay funny
bone
i did the green bay funny bone one time
that place i was
i was starting to do the row when that
place was still open yeah it was still
open like i got booked there and i got
canceled as a feature they never
reopened it they couldn't compete with
football yes something was not right the
week i was there
well yeah that's all those people i mean
everything was not right when i was
there like that was one of those clubs
that was like south beach
yeah it's not gonna work or something's
it's like new orleans you ever go to the
comedy club in new orleans this is never
gonna work miami south beach all that
[ __ ] people walking around naked they
put three [ __ ] clubs down there i got
booked once to a place there was four
people there you're not gonna compete
with that [ __ ] yeah and i think that
that was the problem in green bay i
loved the city i [ __ ] went up there i
went to the game and those that's what i
did
you know you go from that 500 a week
feature act to 650. yeah 650 that
loosens you up a little weak maybe yeah
you take a couple nights off a blow now
sunday you go to a baseball game so i
got into that for a while that was fun i
would go to these cities and go to
baseball games on sunday and then show
up to the club that's my favorite seven
o'clock i love doing that that's a blast
on away weekend and you know you're
gonna go
you know uh today and you wouldn't know
it wasn't like what i was doing it
wasn't like hold on before i take that
week let me see if the packers are in
town that way no no you just get into
town and ask the host and you go hey hey
are they in town this week oh yeah i
think they are in town this week you can
still get tickets you go down there with
the cheeseheads and you're like what are
you talking about yeah like that that
was what i still like
lee asked a really interesting question
in retrospect
leave it to me and you right now
i would give my arm to go on two weeks
of triple runs
to places that nobody goes to we would
sell out the rooms we'll have a great i
don't care if it's a monday night in
those towns
there's nothing to do on some of those
triple towns you'll drive for two hours
and they actually put fake deer up
that's where you drive sometimes where
there's no civilization your phone is
not gonna work you better have a tank of
gas and then you get to this little
hotel
and you go to the back and there's 350
people on a saturday night and they
don't know who you are yeah you could
tell them whatever you want i did a
movie with brad pitt and the movie they
don't know nothing they could care less
they could care less they're just gonna
have to drink laugh and then the band
comes on after us yeah
and you're the g and you're if you have
a good set you're a [ __ ] god oh my
god you're a [ __ ] god
like dads are like here's my daughter
please [ __ ] her i don't care if it's in
front of me really is crazy in those
small towns how much they appreciate
comedy when you go there dude i walked
in and you know i i'm starting to do
this now where like if i have a gig like
in a big city i'll try to book like a
small town gig nearby
like salida colorado is like one of my
most favorite places to go ever it's
just a small town but after the show do
me and the feature act walked into the
restaurant across the street and people
applauded
when we walked in the [ __ ] door
like where does that happen nowhere
except for those small towns it's just
like and that's you're right that's
what's great about going into these
places
it's just like you just get
you're literally like caesar
i could write a book just from 1995
to 2000 that would end in 2000 joey diaz
the garage days the road like broke
eluding uh
creditors like i just
i got divorced things weren't working
out i went into major debt and one day i
said you know what i was showing up to
i was showing up to one nighters and the
manager would go somebody just called
here for you they left the number like i
thought it was hbo yeah yeah i'd call
him back mr diaz discover card i go oh
my god
so i disconnected everything i owned and
i just got in the car i put a [ __ ]
pole in the back i put clothes a
football a frisbee
are the doors open i put everything
anti-boredom yeah and as the weeks pack
your car blows up and you figure out how
to fix it the radiator would blow and
you'd buy that thing for a dollar you
put it into your radio the ping pang
poon yeah yeah it gets you to the next
trip hope for the best i got arrested
shoplifting a tent
and twin falls idaho i got arrested for
assault in twin falls idaho
oh yeah on those triple runs i was a
[ __ ] menace on those things
same incident or a separate incident
they didn't really catch me shoplifting
they caught me bringing the tent back
and collecting the 178 dollars right
okay but they didn't catch me till after
the fact they let me keep the money the
dumb [ __ ] that they were the assault
charge was after a weekend triple had
two weeks
in a row that he would have a wednesday
at one club and a thursday at the other
club right across the street yeah yeah
so the one week i'm in 24 hours on
wednesday and i gotta go back to the
next week on thursday
the two guys that got thrown out show up
to the [ __ ] mall and i hit them with
a [ __ ] tray of chinese food and i got
arrested and they let me out at five to
nine right before the show started and i
ended up fingering an indian chick with
a yeast infection
better than uncle joey you know what i'm
saying
that's not something you found out until
after that's
you know getting a call you know getting
paid 250 and having 50 bucks because you
bought an eight ball that's on you [ __ ]
yeah yeah that's on you [ __ ] you
shouldn't have bought that because you
buy the a boy you're like well it'll
last me for four weekends unless you
want to follow us no no i don't ask you
we're gonna be killing that triple hotel
room and be paranoid and talk to [ __ ]
weird people that's what i do
now i'd have to live on 50 bucks 20 of
it was gas yeah so that's 30 bucks
that's 15 a day for food shelter i'd
have a box of quarters in the back
you always had weed oh absolutely we'll
see yeah yeah that was always my thing
that was the thing you always had weed i
always had weed that's that's the only
thing that gets you through that ship
i would do it in a heartbeat but i
couldn't be away from my family for two
weeks
yeah that'd be tough that's the point i
am of my life now
you know she's getting to an age now
that
when i'm not around bro she starts
asking yeah and you know naturally it
breaks your [ __ ] heart you're in
pittsburgh
you know
but i am keeping the lights on you know
you're gonna have to rationalize it that
way and say i'm keeping the lights on
but i'm getting to a point where
it's gonna be tough pretty soon she's
one day she's gonna raise her hand and
go i'm going with you you know she's a
free spirit i can see it already yeah
and next you know i got her and the
mother on a [ __ ] plane with me or her
by herself
she always talks about getting on a
plane with me and mommy you stay
oh yeah i'm just gonna go with daddy you
know what i'm saying and see what he
does you know but i don't want to take
it to a [ __ ] gig no no no no i can't
have a watch me do stand up at this
point because then she's i don't want to
be a class clown i don't ever want to
know i do stand up to
well she doesn't even know you do stand
up [ __ ] four oh she's four yeah she
doesn't know she don't know dick i tell
her work and that covers all the bases
tell her you're superman she can't yeah
she i tell her i'm spiderman's cousin
she just looks at me daddy the suit
won't fit or something she makes
something i'm a cousin i'm the stats guy
i do a lot of tech
off stuff
you know you sit here and you go how
much work do i put like i put a segment
of my life into comedy
i was talking to josh wolf today and i
said i got into comedy like i was the
type of guy that always ran
and walked a lot when i moved to la i
got into common i forgot about health
eating
you know all i thought about was getting
on stage
and
doing drugs and having a good time at
the [ __ ] club but i was always
writing and i always hung in there you
know i would go home coked up and write
10 pages of material next day you wake
up and
it's all garbage but at least you move
the pet around a little bit yeah so but
we also came up at a time
me at the end of a time when you could
do like when we were still
it was okay to be a bit of a rock star a
little bit now all these especially all
the people younger than us
no there's nobody causing havoc on the
room no no no no they're it's over you
ask for a weed at a club now they're
like what what no no they they still
wait for uncle joey i gotta train
these [ __ ] no i got him trained
yeah but it used to be like they would
walk in the green room and just be like
who needs weed who needs blow you know
it was rockstar
and now we're and now
most of funny puns and improvs are at a
mall you know you're three doors down
from a gnc
it's just it's a different thing there
is nobody on the road today causing
problems there's nobody canceling shows
no there's nobody you hear people
falling off stools people cancel radio
no they can't find them the next day
those days they won't tolerate i don't
think no there's too much talent there's
so much time i don't think they could
handle it now i don't think they can
handle mitch hedberg now towards the end
mitch was cancelling gigs oh yeah yeah
and [ __ ] you know it was just a
nightmare towards the end and
it was accepted he was mitch hedberg you
know he would just mention his name and
he would sell out four [ __ ] shows on
the sunday night yeah yeah you know and
then they couldn't wake him up i mean
you know it was like uh
it was very sad i mean it was just and
you heard it on monday
you know it was all over the wire on
monday there was no internet in those
days it was the phone burning you know
did you hear about mitch did you hear
about [ __ ] this guy i remember when
what's his name was on the tab for a
while george lopez oh yeah i first got
into comedy and when i first moved down
here
george lopez was on a tear yeah
like i met him at a show once and he was
very nice to me
and one day i'm going to dc dulles i'm
delayed
and i walk into the airplane joey dear
george love hey how are you doing you're
delaying unbelievable tequila time i'm
like oh no and i don't know when in
those days i could handle it tequila i
was probably coming down for some
martian dust
before
this [ __ ] told the [ __ ] guy
at the bar to leave the bottle there
yeah he put like a car down and we sat
there
i got on that plane i was i slept the
whole way stevie wonder was on the plane
i didn't give a [ __ ]
[Laughter]
i slept the whole [ __ ] way the dulles
i was hammered
and then i went down to
miami and they said uh no it's not
what's his name it's george lopez you're
featuring for
so tuesday he [ __ ] did great
in those days he was killing yelling
right before sandra bullock discovered
him he was killing
he killed tuesday he killed wednesday
thursday i come out and he snap dawg
like he destroyed the room but by the
time
he went up on stage he had already a few
tequilas in him
and then he came on a [ __ ] stage and
he sat at that improv
with us i don't know if i know i don't
think he was doing he wasn't the drug
addict at all at all
i know i was doing powders that's what
was keeping me alive next to him
and the next morning my father was
ringing off the hook in that [ __ ]
miami condo do you know which one i'm
talking about oh the one that was right
across the street
oh my god that was the condo of death
dude i remember i scored weed from a guy
like just standing out on the balcony
yeah yeah that balcony there and i was
i'd be sitting there and the guy's like
this guy came out and he's like what's
up man i was like man i could use some
weed he's like i got you it was that
easy
like i [ __ ] loved that condo
you have
no idea what i did in that [ __ ] condo
and see now i'm glad i i know
that was the condo with a bed you had to
pull it from this there was a charlie
baby it was a charlie bed
i used to tie chicks up and leave the
ropes just cut them loose in the morning
and [ __ ] i used to lit up dog
i went in there one time after pablo
there was those poppers everywhere those
[ __ ] there was it was [ __ ] crazy
yeah
there was a couple condos that were
known that one el paso
i never did el paso
as soon as you went to el paso there'd
be a note go up on top of the cabinet
in the condo and it'd be like a [ __ ]
grandma blowing it was everywhere
you could buy coke for five cents in el
paso in those days yeah
they were just but that condo in
coconut grove yeah was they used to have
a condo around the corner
when i first went to coconut grove i
went there i was very respectful i was
very honored to be there i was going to
go up in front of cubans so in those
days
the condo was two or three blocks away
and you didn't hear a [ __ ] peeply
you were like this sucks
so in those days comedy was tuesday
through sunday so tuesday night sucked
you know the show ended at 9 30 and
there were people there but i didn't
really have money to party you know and
even if i did
this town sucks i walked back to the
condo and i didn't hear nothing yeah by
thursday i'm [ __ ] starving i smoke
some weed i'm starving
i walk down to that thing and i got to
be honest there must have been 10 000
people on those streets cars couldn't
get you that's some coconut grove
was coconut was the place
it was [ __ ] hard it was like
i've been in my house for two [ __ ]
days and thinking that this was dead
this just comes alive at 11. yeah when
i'd be walking back at 9 30 the streets
would be dead
dead
you walk out an hour and a half away
that hotel was where all the basketball
players stayed and uh if uh they whoever
played the miami heat
up the corner from the improv oh that's
sinesta that whatever that [ __ ] place
is walking distance from the improv
across the news cafe when the news cafe
was there yeah that hotel was where the
knicks and anybody stayed there that
played the heat
so it was always happening they had an
italian restaurant under the coconut
grove improv that it was a [ __ ] fine
eatery like
oh big champagne glasses that was back
when it was on the third floor third
floor but on the at 11 o'clock chicks
would be naked dancing on the table you
come down and you look and there'd be a
woman topless
because it would the italian that would
go crazy they'd start giving out powder
in there there would be a guy playing
the piano did she work there or she just
like at the restaurant she was
downstairs at the restaurant at night
there was various nights when i was
walking past the improv and i looked in
there with 22 in my pocket and those
slurpy drinks
that they had that's right that the
place right outside it was uh
140
different icees
[ __ ] so if you work the improv they give
you two free drinks i get the strongest
one 140 [ __ ] uh it was just basically
bacardi 151 yeah
151 frozen with red they set it on fire
oh you wake up in the morning you puke
it be red you throw your kidney blew up
horrible this little mall i've never
prayed for death more than in florida
that by sunday night
you would be green
yeah by sunday night from all the sugar
and the blow and the not sleeping
your skin would be green you got sick of
eating because they had sorry they used
to have the stuff flounder with lobster
meat and shrimp
do you remember that that was especially
the miami improv oh the stuffed flounder
with the lobster meat and the shrimp
yeah well eat two of those
and in my mind i'd go the cocaine is
gone i'm ready [ __ ] snow
the iodine and the blow and the fish
killed the [ __ ] coke i'm ready to go
my favorite was the hollywood florida
improv because they had bars down there
that wouldn't even open until two in the
morning so you do shows you do three
shows on a saturday get out there like 1
30 get into a club that just opened i'd
drink till 5
and then i'd walk into the hard rock and
take tourist money and poker
for [ __ ] three hours and then i go
upstairs at nine a.m and order breakfast
with other people's money
because the first night i was there in
fort lauderdale i was like i'm paying
poker with this guy and we went to the
we went to the end and he had nothing
like why did you stay in this logo son
i'm in here to gamble not play poker
from then on i knew that these
[ __ ] were just drunk so i would
just come in like [ __ ] doc holiday
and just take these [ __ ] i
ended up doubling my merch money at the
poker table
just coming home getting wasted
it was awesome
one of the things i always loved about
you was
you're a professional i mean you're uh
when you were out there there was no
faking it
this is not the guy that goes on stage
with a beer bottle to let people know no
you were [ __ ] going yeah you go you
know that's what i always loved about it
first mail this [ __ ] dude is the real
deal
he's not one of these candy
[ __ ] that walks around and sips
a drink on stage who's drinking tequila
[ __ ] you i drank tequila for breakfast
[ __ ] yeah smell my breath i literally
just woke up yeah like you just woke up
like this it's a different life
you know and then we grow up and we go
what the [ __ ] am i doing these people
are paying to come see me you know
exactly anymore yeah i mean
we were talking earlier about how much a
feature act is the second comic that
goes on stage there's zero
responsibility your responsibility is to
do two things make them laugh for 25
minutes and try to kill the headliner
which you never do unless you're local
and you hit them with local references
then the guy swims in debt for two
nights until he figures out what the
[ __ ] you're doing that's correct then he
starts coming up with local references
yeah yeah you know you start talking
about the local news yeah judge who got
arrested for [ __ ] the black [ __ ]
[ __ ] and they
they they just blow up and this guy's in
the back going i forgot to read the
paper
what the [ __ ] did i do i read the usa
today i should have read the chattanooga
times oh dude i don't know how many yeah
there's so many times on thursday you're
just looking at the kid go wait till
saturday [ __ ] yeah like you like
get go ahead guy i just landed
you know what i'm saying like i'm still
tired you [ __ ] you do you
it's a different life to be a feature
act and it's
i think i did it from 95
to 2005. i mean that was a really good
feature actually i know and from time to
time people that you have wine on
wednesday
but i tell people at the time i didn't
become a real headliner until about six
years ago yeah like i was just up there
i had an hour a big [ __ ] deal no no
no no it's
the guys like you the word smith you
really put the time and that's
completely different i was never a
headliner like that until
the podcast and things started and i'm
like [ __ ] i can't just go up there and
play johnny acapella yeah it doesn't cut
it when people are paying 20 bucks you
got to go out there with your heart and
laying on the [ __ ] line so they could
go home and go what the [ __ ] did we just
see yeah this is crazy you lay it down
too i love that when i go on the road to
some clubs
i'm like who comes in here and [ __ ]
people up and they're like oh [ __ ]
crisp order and i'm like you guys didn't
know like minneapolis was the real shock
there was one other club i went to that
you were either coming or you had just
left three weeks early
welcome was cleveland
i don't know where the [ __ ] it was well
bronson's house of comedy i was i had
never played that's what they said yeah
they're like they had no idea
and also my my on stage
i mean it's still me
the the the person i play on stage is
much angrier and abrupt than i am so
when i come in i'm like hey how's it
going it's super nice to meet you
they're like well who's this [ __ ]
idiot
and then i get on stage and i [ __ ]
bring the heat and like oh okay that's
that guy
it's a bit weird when did you get on the
last comic stand not the first season
that was four season four that was ten
years ago uh 11 years ago and that was
ralphie no that was uh two seasons after
ralphie wow yeah so rafi was on the
second season he was on season two then
they had season three that had like
alonzo won it okay it was season one
versus season two i think
and then they canceled it like before
they announced it
and then i was in the season with
[ __ ] gabriel and josh blue and ty
barnett and roz g and all those who won
that year josh blue josh blue but gabe
got ejected for using his cell phone
so
right
we kind of dodged a huge bull
that's right he was in the house for two
weeks or something i thought he lasted
like yeah we were on the boat and you
know we all knew he was talking to his
girl none of us gave a [ __ ] you know
they had they have a bunch of [ __ ]
rules because like oh he could be
talking to writers i'm like it's [ __ ]
fluffy dude he's not talking to anybody
and uh but we knew his girlfriend just
had surgery or whatever so we're all
cool with it but he got caught on camera
texting her and so they're like you
gotta go
how crazy is that yeah yeah
[ __ ] and the and the funny thing is
they did interviews with all of us and
literally nine of the 11 of us were like
yeah we're fine with it like we know
what he's doing and we're happy that
he's kind of got the balls to do it and
they they played the two chicks they
were like well rules are rules
so yeah now you have to go on a house
then no
yeah we did we had to well we didn't
have a house we were on the queen mary
for 10 days
yeah do you have to share a room i'm
sorry it was so long ago i don't
remember if you had to well i shared a
room with bill dwyer but he got
eliminated pretty quickly so i had to i
had my own room for smoke weed on the
boat
no no that was the first thing i did as
soon as i was a as soon as i was off the
boat was i went straight to my friend's
house and got 10 days on the ship with
no reefer dude it was about did they
search you on the way in
um well they just said don't bring
marijuana it's maritime rules [ __ ] you
no i had weed in the i had weed during
the semifinals and whatnot
uh
trying to think i think i just yeah i
think i just run out but we were on
camera at all times there were cameras
everywhere so there wasn't we didn't
there wasn't anywhere i would have lost
those [ __ ] i would have
flattened their tires you know me
i would have put sugar in that gas tank
they would have got hit right before
they go on the 101 the car stalls i'm a
[ __ ] master of flattery we got suit
like we we turned into big drunks on
that boat for sure because as soon as we
got done filming all the [ __ ] it was
just like it was poker
and and drinks it's
but they shot you 24 hours a day yeah we
were on camera like there were cameras
in your room right yeah they had cameras
oh my god you couldn't whack off and as
soon as the first person woke up they
had fluorescent lights that came on
and so as soon as the first person was
up everyone was up
and i mean i'm sure they somewhere in an
nbc vault there's video of me screaming
at a security camera going
are you [ __ ] like i'm just losing my
mind like just turn off the lights so i
can sleep
and they wouldn't do it
i think that's like the worst part about
reality tv like that's i i worked on the
post out of reality tv when i first
moved here
and
they like they are they're just
constantly then they have people
directing the cameras they've produced
is there all night so they'll zoom it's
they'll zoom in on you while you're
sleeping they get shots of that they
want it's uh
i i don't think i could be like whenever
i saw the real world and there were like
four people in a room sleeping together
that would how that would be out i would
be out immediately you know i shot a
presentation for animal planet like a
month ago
and i really
realized how much
like what i could do and what i can do
like me and the guy are great friends
now but he goes the first couple days it
was really hard to crack your nut
because
you know what man if this is a job this
is a job but i really don't want nobody
in my house yeah
okay you want to take me you want to
tape me
tape me from jumping in the lift and
going to the airport
that's fine the guy would go to me and
then one day i and i he would always say
to me well what cats will come out
because we try to think about cats
i must have told this [ __ ] guy 80
times that these cats ain't going to
come out
and one [ __ ] day i'm walking and he
asked my wife like after he asked me
anytime you thought he was cute you know
what i'm saying like [ __ ]
and i had to pull him aside and i go
listen when i tell you something i only
tell you one [ __ ] time i don't give a
[ __ ] what executive you are all right he
just turned pale
yeah he apologized later and i realized
that
i'm at a point right now i don't want to
cam in my [ __ ] face anymore i enjoy
doing this
but for me
to to have people in my home and look in
my bathroom and me and my bed listen i
don't need it that much i don't wanna
it's rough
i will have no idea it's [ __ ] rough i
woke up one morning during last comic
standing with a three-cam person camera
crew staring at me
like sound guy audio guy mike guy
just staring at me as i wake up like oh
hey guys
good morning
i have a boner
sorry like it's not bad enough we got
the right material and everything but
then you got to push the envelope list i
don't mind doing it but five hours of
the day let me get my head together let
me write at the starbucks let me go to
the library let me jerk off let me smoke
a bowl of weed you can't be how about
from eight to [ __ ] twelve you're on
me or whatever you know like i don't
mind that but i can't have you
following me that day is sunk that on
here what about no tv no internet no
phone
that's not gonna happen that's not worth
it to me either
there's no reason why you should do that
to me that's just a personal thing you
come up with to bust my boss
you know you have a family really yeah
really no i don't think so bro
you know you can't make the exclusion
for the family do you have a family yeah
how about you come in the [ __ ] house
with me
and i call your [ __ ] family for a
week go [ __ ] yourself no no no that's
why i couldn't that's why even with
animal planet and the presentation i was
very excited about but then i thought
about the process and i'll do it with
contingencies my house is all [ __ ]
limits
i don't want nobody around my [ __ ]
house i don't want no camera creepy
people
waking me up i'm upsetting my animals
it's not worth the aggravation bro you
know yeah i was 26 when i mean to be
fair like
you didn't know for what last conference
oh yeah well good for you it was
brilliant yeah and but it and it wasn't
my house i was staying on a ship that
was
had been docked for 12 years or like so
like i knew i was in for but yeah i mean
it's just but in those moments you're
just like what the [ __ ] am i getting
myself into no you don't know somebody
comes up to you and says we're gonna pay
you [ __ ] this you're gonna be on a
national show and you're a young comic
you're like okay except when you're
taking a [ __ ] and there's a camera in
that [ __ ] bathroom you know is that
really necessary and you know what 10
days is 10 days yeah i think by 14 days
people start to snap and there'll be
arguments and oh dude we had talks at
lunch off camera just like like people
sneaking like did you how did you like
it was like a bet who could jerk off
and it was just like how'd you do it and
you know one of them would just be like
i just did it like in front of the
cameras if they want to show it
if they want to watch i don't give a
[ __ ] like i just did it and it was like
i remember i snuck to a bathroom to do
it because i was like there's no cameras
in here and i [ __ ] it's been a week
like i need i gotta drain this [ __ ] but
it was a great experience all though
dude it changed my life dude there was i
went from
i literally made 10 times as much money
that year than i did like the 10 years
previous yeah yeah i made more in one
week that year than i did the year
previous
like oh my god yeah that's crazy that's
fast it rose and i knew it when it was
how i was like i made more this week
than i made all last year
and you know
that ended a long time ago but in that
9 11 months that was [ __ ] that was
good times
i remember ralphie lost at that fan and
i was supposed to open from
the week after last comic ended and
that's spider-man 2. okay and john
wesling went and i remember people
calling me going when he got to the last
stop there was 300 people waiting for
him outside in those days like it was
that huge the country
had really embraced it it was [ __ ]
huge yeah
i had never even showed i never even
thought about standing online i'm like
i'm not going down there yeah i'm not
gonna go down i was like embarrassed i'm
like i don't know what i'm gonna do if i
go down there and i would watch the
audition tapes
and i would watch top comics go out of
there losing their [ __ ] mind yeah
who was the one guy here now you could
close that forum by love there was one
[ __ ] guy one year
that went nuts i forget what his name is
and he told the cameras to go [ __ ]
themselves in the audition that he
settles out rooms everywhere and
i don't know who that is but i know i
[ __ ] flipped out at one point did you
shoot [ __ ] yeah dude we
they
we're going to bed at like 11 at night
we're wasting we've been playing poker
all night and they're like oh call times
2 am
right [ __ ] like in three hours yeah
and we shot the adam corolla thing
but for whatever reason we didn't go
until five we got there like three in
the morning it was just a [ __ ]
psychological ploy to keep us up so when
we got in we were exhausted or whatever
but when we got back where they kept us
up because they said that we're like
we're all going to bed
and they're like no we're having
breakfast
and so then we're like we don't want
breakfast we just want to go to bed and
they're like well you have to stay up
for breakfast and then we got up there
and there was no breakfast they were
they're like oh it's not ready yet and
me and another comic [ __ ] lost our
minds like [ __ ] pushing over
furniture
like what the [ __ ] like we want we
didn't even want this [ __ ] and you made
us stay up for it yeah no no like and we
lost and you know they they didn't show
any of that they could have like they're
i was definitely
i'm surprised like yeah no they would
never do something to discredit
themselves i thought they would make
themselves look like savages and no i
thought they were going to use it for
like
next week on last comic standing and use
some of it but not if like two comics
argue with something they'd use it to
create a little bit of drama but yeah
but
something where they're keeping us up
and we're like we don't want this and
you're making a stay up for it you know
that's hard to [ __ ]
spin you know when i got here i was
having no success as a comic so i
figured for me to slip out the back door
i would become an actor and book rolls
you know yeah
and you know now in hindsight i because
i had this desire you know i
at the time i ignored a lot of things
that happened the first two years like
you know
again i'm not crying because it was one
of the biggest [ __ ] movie
stupid things i ever did in one day
what's the movie with [ __ ] uh david
spade i think when he fights the [ __ ]
[ __ ] in the beginning and
that joe dirt
i don't [ __ ] know i did one of those
movies oh yeah i was one of the boxing
trainers to the [ __ ]
and bobby slayton was the ring and
answer okay
our call time was 5 a.m
you know what time we shot
12 15 at night
like most human beings that are normal
would go
[ __ ] you yeah yeah like [ __ ] you that's
not even close like you're not even
close again it was twilight time you
have no idea so when you work on a film
the first eight hours is whatever
then the second two hours is time and a
half
then the two hours after that is like
double [ __ ] time yeah and after that
they have to pay you for the whole
[ __ ] day all over again even if you
stay there for 15 minutes
yeah those big budgeted movies back in
98 when they didn't give a [ __ ] yeah i
mean i got home at 3 30 in the morning
but it was like in those days it was
like a five grand check i had never seen
a check for five [ __ ] grand for some
stupid movie but i was there the whole
day when i shot baseball i didn't know
what i got myself into yeah yeah it was
a dirty comment i don't even know what
the [ __ ] going on i don't know what
then go to your mark what what are you
talking about
i didn't do nothing i don't know mark
there's no nothing no steve i'm a comic
you tell me to be there at 7 15 it's
cause i'm going on stage at 8 15. yeah
you told me to be there at 7 45 it's
cause i'm going on stage at 8 15 8 30. i
would get that five in the morning and
they would come to me at 10 at night and
go you're wrapped
you made me come all the way down here
not knowing that i was getting scale i'm
not crying
but there's a lot of situations like
that the longest yard you don't know how
many times they
cut us
oh yeah and as you're going into the
hotel room they call you and go we're
coming back guys
all the tattoos gotta get and by the
time they put the tattoos in the
shoulder pads on you we lost the light
see you at six tomorrow morning oh son
of a [ __ ] oh my [ __ ] god but yeah
you know when i did that movie there was
a certain contract yeah this is how they
got you they paid you okay but
whether you worked or not you still had
to be there five days a week okay it was
like a c contract until you shot out you
had to be there every day they didn't
give a [ __ ] because they might want to
shoot a different scene so you would
wait there all day that's what
got me the toughness of
learning how to adjust on films it took
me five years to work around sets
to not get pissed off by the time i
[ __ ] left
to not get into an argument you know
when i got out of here you shot a couple
if you went for a commercial it said
august 8th
through august 13th that means they were
going to shoot monday tuesday wednesday
thursday friday guess what if your
commercial shot thursday in those days
they'd say
see you monday
yeah and you went there you brought a
magazine you got sun you got high and
you went home after eight hours but they
paid you for the whole week book a
commercial today jack
when you get there it says august 8th to
the 13th and you're going home going
like oh [ __ ] yeah paul and also they
call you like you work in one day and
you get there at eight and they're like
we're shooting four commercials today
you're gonna be wrapped by ten you're
like you motherless [ __ ]
you just ruined my [ __ ] day for two
[ __ ] hours because by that point you
want overtime when i go to a set i want
to be there all day like now yeah i want
to be there all day but now that don't
exist no more me now you get there
they're like you're gonna be at home by
lunch and you're like are you [ __ ]
serious
i'm really just gonna get 695 a day plus
10. what the [ __ ]
you're looking for that overtime yeah
but no that's how i learned tonight that
was an education to me sitting around
all day and
you know you got all this energy and you
want to use the phone and yeah and i
didn't bring a computer in those days i
would just show up and be in a [ __ ]
room smaller than this staring at a
toilet yeah for 12 hours then
once i started getting representation
then they give you a room with a tv but
the vcr don't work
you know the bathroom don't flush
then they give
they give you
then they start giving you more stuff
you know like because your agent says
hey no [ __ ] like i would do these
disney hundred dollar day movies it was
like prison yeah yeah this is [ __ ]
disney and they're putting in these
trailers that they had like nazi
villains in there and [ __ ] like that
they had like [ __ ]
did they like to say if you fart the
whole trailer would stink
yeah you know those things you get
pissed off and you work those things
like why not even take this [ __ ]
stupid job
oh man this is what we chose
and we forget the abuse we took
yeah but also i go home and i like tell
my fri try bitching about that to your
friends
back home oh i'm not bitching i'm just
saying that yeah yeah but you're like
they're like how's life with you and
you're like oh [ __ ] i only made 6.95
yesterday and they're like [ __ ] you [ __ ]
you i made that last week you [ __ ]
pray
i made that last month yeah
695 plus scale is that what the union is
now you worked recently anything no it's
more than that because i remember
you know even during
last comic 10 years ago we were making
seven something yeah seven some that was
after though yeah that was that's after
them yeah after after and they merged so
now they really don't want to pay yeah
like now you get a movie you're like
what i'll stay home
i'll stay home by the time i get to
marina del rey every day and the
animation and the [ __ ] dry cleaning
i'm breaking even forget it like you
can't believe you live here anymore yeah
like you really can't like you move out
here you take acting lessons and one day
you're like well you know people tell
you come on wait till you book a pilot
you're gonna make fifty thousand dollars
i never made more than two thousand
dollars for a pilot that was always the
[ __ ] yeah and buried on the 50 000 is
for the guy that wrote it and it starred
in it and [ __ ] did all like the the
lottery winner
please no that's that's the thing with
and people at home going joy what the
[ __ ] are you talking about i had to work
two weeks and i'm not complaining about
that
when you first get there and you don't
know what you're
going for and you're sitting there for
eight hours it does get aggravating the
first couple times regardless of what
you're making because you you've been
working all your life you know you came
here to work you didn't tell me to
[ __ ] sit down you know
it's weird because you know you don't
have the check right there so it's still
it's still annoying you just got it just
it doesn't matter how much you're making
people can still get annoyed about
anything
wow i don't know about that because i
know when i was in last comic standing i
was like oh well i'm making seven eight
hundred dollars today and i've never
yeah i used to make that a week you
could hit me in the head with a hammer
for 800 hours a day two times yeah at
that point when you first moved here as
long as i get a lunch in between yeah
yeah a little lunch in between the heads
you know when you first move here it's
15 a spot 12 50 at the improv and you're
trying to make [ __ ] rent which is
minimal yeah it's 200 your rent you live
with three savages your living house
smells like [ __ ] do you sleep in a
hallway you sleep in a hallway your
hallway oh my god
my friend was a coke dealer
and he had one of his friends living in
the closet and it was the funniest thing
in the world i go in and buy coke at
four in the morning you open up the
closet though like the closet under the
steps yeah and i looked in there one day
it was beautiful
yeah yeah
a little fan for ventilation yeah it was
beautiful if you're going to live in a
closet you can view it i mean it was you
had posters up here a little nintendo
and a computer yeah and he goes i come
in here and i put the fan on and i crack
the door and i get ventilation no
windows but he was happy with what he
had
i got a letter from mari today
yeah
wait okay what how long has it been
uh january 1st he left i think
ari
sofia oh yeah he sent you a letter like
titanic style yeah from [ __ ] wherever
he is some other country really didn't
even tell me where he was at just wrote
a new york return address
it had via a mail on it a bunch of
chinese writing russian writing it went
through [ __ ] like 19 customs a dog
and it was really funny because uh it
was very interesting he said that uh he
told me the places where he had been
yeah and he said that he couldn't get
drugs at those places so he's been drug
free
for the whole time on this trip and it
really uh cleared his mind you know yeah
and then uh
he's staying at hostels
with 12 to 16 people sleeping in the
room
and at first he was very scared but it
was very humbling for him like he's
you know he was here for a long time i
think that
my wife asked me and i said you know if
i didn't have you
and i didn't have the kid
and
you go on the road for six weeks in a
row you come back
that thing you shot didn't get picked up
one day you go you know what
i just want to go to [ __ ] somewhere
for six weeks and think about my faith
yeah yeah gabriel glacier just did it
gabriel canceled this tour yeah he got
he had a health problem though no he had
you know one day you wake up and you go
i've been doing this for a long time
i've been everywhere i've done arenas
i've done big [ __ ] productions in
movies
but at the same time i've neglected a
lot of things yeah it's like i neglected
my health when i first moved to l.a
when you go on you know
and again this is not somebody crying or
you know
we were talking about plane rides how
you put earplugs in
before you travel because the [ __ ]
the noises at the airport you know
now like we've been flying for 20 years
we prepare ourselves to fly i'm ready
for a delay i got
weed sticks i got xanax i got an ipod i
got a notebook i got a pen i got a vapor
pen i mean i'm ready to fly you want to
delay me that's fine i'm going to get
[ __ ] up
i got edibles hidden somewhere oh
absolutely always always
but you do that every [ __ ] week and
there's a guy that listen it was in
forbes he made 10 million dollars
he made 10 million dollars but if you
pull up his schedule for the last 10
years
he only takes like july off if that
every year like if that you know he
shoots two tv shows he's got he bought a
warehouse
you know he's in demand he travels
abroad i mean this guy does two shows on
christmas [ __ ] day yeah sells out the
irvine improv on christmas day
does that 18 and over show
you know you got to come home one day
and go wait a second i gotta
let me slow down for six weeks and see
where i want to go ari
one day called me ari canceled the
schedule last year
okay
ari canceled called his agent one day
and said
cancel the rest of my work
yeah and the agent was like i don't know
what's going on and then
ari just wanted to take a [ __ ]
vacation he's been here working hard you
know
when you
i think it's better to want than to have
uh
i got a friend i got a call from a
friend of mine today mr [ __ ] i'm
shooting a pilot yeah
you know everybody wants to shoot a
[ __ ] pilot and sell it to somebody i
don't even raise my hand because it's
none of my business i always know it's
bad business to shoot a pilot and try to
sell it yeah no it's very hard to shoot
a pilot and try to sell in today's
economy i walk in there with somebody
that's backwards yeah somebody wants he
wants to walk and i appreciate his thing
and his ferocity you never can get in
somebody's way
but he got a call and he was supposed to
shoot the pilot at three o'clock with a
name
okay guys a name
yeah and at late in the morning he got a
call the guy canceled
the guy goes here's the story i got to
do a photo shoot in new york and because
of the snowstorm
i can't go on thursday they want me to
fly in tonight
yeah so this guy was literally [ __ ] by
god you know [ __ ] by god
at the last goddamn minute that's my
foot i'm sorry it did sound like it did
sound like enough
[ __ ] man god's [ __ ] on top of it but
it's uh
what are we talking about i got too high
there for a second
oh yeah
huh
mister shoot a pilot
remember
to shoot a pilot calls and that's you
know he [ __ ] tells me that the guy
canceled them and yeah last minute
you know yeah i don't even know what the
purpose of the story was anymore that's
how high
thank god i stopped eating edibles you
should
what do you got going on brother well we
already released a new album okay um no
special no no netflix didn't
netflix didn't want it so you said [ __ ]
you i'm taping something anyway and
releasing it yeah i mean you know i
released my first record with stand-up
records so i figured they'd be pretty
responsive if i wanted to give them
something they were so i was just tired
of the hour but
i knew it was a decent hour one worth
putting out absolutely and so i just
i sat on it for a little bit i just kept
doing it and doing it so that it was
ready
and then it got to a point where i'm
like i'm just slowing myself down so
called stand-up records and said let's
do this and they're like let's do it so
as a matter of fact i have to listen to
the final cut tomorrow and then it'll be
out within weeks i think so
you're still hustling man and that's the
most important like don't you ever i say
it to myself every day no matter what
the [ __ ] going on i'm still here
absolutely dude every day i get paid to
tell jokes is good like i i'm definitely
i definitely know what ari's talking
about and and that [ __ ] you go through
i'm just not at a place where i could
walk away no no no no no and it was like
i think it's better that's what my story
was it's better to want them to have
sometimes yeah sometimes you move to
this town when are we first got this is
not happening on comedy central yeah the
first call he got was from duncan trump
so going dog before you say yes analyze
this
and get ready to get mind [ __ ] get
ready to get calls from networks and
executives and yeah people that don't
know nothing about anything they're all
seeing you and giving you rules he goes
it's going to wear on you yeah he goes i
did the math after i got the deal and
shot the pilot joey he goes i made no
money but the time i put in the not re
yeah duncan was saying this at lunch one
day he called hari and ari said i
understand
and ari was getting to a point that he
was going on the road
you know like i said it's tough enough
doing comedy now i got comedy central
calling me all day on thursday and
friday giving me notes and wanting
you're trying to write your material
you're trying to get your [ __ ] together
now so it's very hard to focus
you know he had had some issues like uh
focusing whatever
and like i said he called one day and he
goes i'm not gonna shoot my special
i'm gonna put it on cold yeah i'm gonna
[ __ ] go to around the world
and get to live life and then try to
write about it he goes he hadn't lived
his life for a while absolutely and i
gotta be honest with you for about the
last three weeks i was kind of upset
deep down inside
like jesus christ not even a [ __ ]
postcard yeah but that's what he said to
me because i couldn't find the [ __ ]
post office for the last
three weeks yeah the letter was overdue
and it made me feel good i understand
what position he's in no dog in 1995
part of the reason i went on that triple
run was because i was gonna be ari
that's it yeah i just almost [ __ ]
beat up a guy i lost my daughter i got
no money i'm not doing nothing here in
denver commonly i was living in boulder
there's no reason for me to live here
comedy works banned me at the time i was
gonna do comedy at the two other clubs
and grow that's not gonna happen
and i got in my car and i went on a
journey man i lived on the road and i
moved to seattle along the way and then
that's i did the same thing he did it
took me three years to settle in that
way dude at the end of the day when
we're on the road we're in a one man
submarine like yeah you you have the
other comics when you're at the shows
but
most the time you guys don't hang out
most of the time you just go back to
your rooms and you chill the [ __ ] out
and you see each other
so sometimes it's nice to get out of the
submarine for a little bit and walk
along the earth
around people to get material you have
to live your life and i think it happens
it happens to musicians where you know i
was watching the thing about black
sabbath they taught incessably
for two and a half years and then they
took [ __ ] eight months off you don't
want to see that person after two and a
half years oh absolutely you don't want
to see that person you don't want to
hear about music you don't want to be
hear about new chords all you want to go
home is just sit in front of your
[ __ ] tv sundays when i get home
all i want to do i don't sit in front of
the [ __ ] tv but sundays i sit in
front of that [ __ ] tv i watch my 60
minutes yeah you know i watch my little
sunday night football for a quarter or
not i watch whatever shows on hbo are
popular with my wife yeah you know i
have to decompress completely i don't go
on the facebook i don't go on twitter i
don't want to know what's on twitter you
yeah you can't comment on this life if
you don't live it if you don't live it
yeah no
i don't know how
there are people and i complain about
this constantly i love them dearly
they're on twitter
but if i go on twitter at six in the
morning they're tweeting
if i go on twitter at two in the
afternoon they just tweeted and if i go
on twitter at 11 o'clock they tweeted
they're on there all day yeah
not looking up
yeah yeah well they're looking up
they're thinking of one thing and
they're going right back down it's
constant it's all [ __ ] day and you
see a whale breathing you have to
you have to give
i think army just needed a break from
that's when i get pissed off when i
start hearing from people
that don't know what they're talking
about yeah like when i was promoting the
cd the dvd for cso
and i was getting calls from people that
were trying to tell me my job and that
pisses me the [ __ ] off i got me here
this far
yeah you're not gonna make me do a radio
tour of am radios from 6 a.m to 9 00
talking to college students about my
career like it's not going to help me
sell dvds did you really go to prison oh
did you drop the soap you know yeah
those are the worst interview interviews
ever yeah yeah they wear you out so let
me be on here let me be on here let me
be funny for five minutes
just ask me about something i don't even
have to do jokes just let's be funny
don't
anytime i go to an interview especially
like you know when we do radio or a
million [ __ ] tv interviews and the
first thing out is like
so what do we expect from your shows i'm
[ __ ] done
it's like it's [ __ ] comedy dude it's
like i'm gonna go up there i'm gonna
talk you obviously did no research
whatsoever they're just [ __ ]
they don't know what the [ __ ] they're
talking about that's most people most
people now because now
like even podcasting it's become like
the age of the director anybody could be
a director today yeah anybody there's no
formal training
they watch three movies they watch three
movies i'm a director
no you're not no you're [ __ ] not guy
no you're not that's why your movies
suck that's why that you got to learn
you got to go back to the 70s to learn
how to direct if you don't study the
guys from the 70s you're not going to be
a good director those were the those are
the ones that sold you the story
visually absolutely they sold the 70s
they had to sell you the story visually
today
that directing isn't accepted because
it's considered a little boring yeah
even the 80s like in the 80s the opening
two minutes of any 80s movie is a car
driving through the woods
like just to a song like that's all it
is sorry about that we're getting hit
with the planes over burbank
but i'll tell you what like i told you
the other day you know what i don't want
to polish podcasts i want you
[ __ ] to think you're listening
to something rated x like you you're
living under a cave and the russians are
looking for you like pirate radio this
is what i want i never want it to be
perfected or edited or people putting
music on the [ __ ] podcast i want you
to hear the burps the farts the
scratching of the nuts
the whole [ __ ] kitten caboodle that's
what we do here on the church
[ __ ] let me do some shout outs
here
i asked you a few more questions and
we'll get the [ __ ] out of here i know
you guys want to go for korean food you
might as well take the little korean
over there i can tell he's starving he's
looking at that sandwich right now he's
about to eat the wrapper oh no
as soon as you guys leave the sandwich
will be gone no they're eating it you
ain't eating that sandwich no you're
gonna have that same sniffing that
[ __ ] baggie we already ate two
sandwiches i want to give smoke a notice
a shout out michael bird song
edwin eddie brancaccio
bobby and crystal dick cyat lorne
rosenka always there leon the man of
steel over there in germany [ __ ]
german chicks by the dozen
purple boss oh gee i love you [ __ ]
and sean
welsh and my man bob lalingus i want to
wish your dad good luck
uh his upcoming procedure thinking about
you always and uh
that's basically the [ __ ] you know
what i'm saying so i don't know what's
gonna happen with these 22 feet of snow
i'm going to [ __ ] baltimore this
weekend a bazooka would have to stop me
you understand me but
they already like i got home this
happened at two o'clock and i saw a
friend of mine post
my kids got no school tomorrow like in
jersey they already declared
and the storm hasn't even formed yet
do you understand that
like that's what i on the news the storm
is not even like there are no clouds
they're just predicting that clouds will
form and make a storm i talked to my
friend lately he said that it feels like
snow is coming yeah you could feel that
coldness so i definitely you know that
feeling
i grew up in this you get that smell in
that air yeah you know when your bones
start to creak a little bit but two feet
of snow so i don't know what's going to
happen it hasn't formed yet and they're
talking about tuesday that means
wednesday yeah that means i'm not taking
no [ __ ] red eye i'm not going on the
la bomba flight
i'm saying what i'm saying
that's the la bomba red eye with [ __ ]
snow coming down and you gotta land with
snow no no no
yeah yeah you get a big bopper to the
next level yeah no [ __ ] you so i don't
know what's gonna happen so i hope you
know i'm gonna be at magooby's comedy a
joke house
you know thursday friday saturday with
the emphasis on [ __ ] thursday
that's when the devil's showing up
[ __ ] so make sure you're there
eight o'clock show
snow sleet hail i don't care if your
grandmother got hit by a truck you
better be there [ __ ]
lee what do you got planned for the
weekend god oh he's going to las vegas
this weekend i am i have uh i'm working
for a little bit and then i get to spend
the night with larry playing blackjack
it's going to be great how about you
take me how many eaters you're taking
with you just 500.
i wish i could bring a couple of g's
that'd be the that's my dream you gotta
dress up on a suit and go play with them
and throw them off this time
throw them off
what what level table you play
uh
like 25 hand five dollar hand no well i
i've been playing 25 around here because
that's all i really have yeah
i really should be playing the 15 so
i'll in vegas i'll play the 15 and and
unless i make a little bit of money then
i'll switch to the 25 but that's still a
little bit much i don't like paying 25
my hand all right
are you very good at so you're very good
at cards you're very proof i play poker
i don't okay
and i'm not very good it's just really
easy to take drunk idiots money you know
and that's who you find at six in the
morning at a [ __ ] hard rock casino so
where do you play do you play and like
where you have to sign up and they call
you over or do you just play against a
dealer i don't play as much i mean i
don't play as much as i used to i'll
play like like if i play a casino like i
used to play the board god in atlantic
city and a few other places like i'll
take a hundred bucks down to the tables
and i'll play the one two tables you
worked a big room with the more guy yeah
well yeah but i don't do it as like my
own show i do you know they they book it
sunday through thursday
with like a three headliners who are
they really
and so then
it used to be monday through sunday and
then like
if they had it booked friday saturday
you would just have friday saturday off
but they'd still give you a room and
[ __ ]
so
sometimes they'd hook you up like i saw
hauling oats one night because i was off
and they had extra tickets so
you know but speaking of whole notes i
mean interrupt you i heard some [ __ ]
up [ __ ] today on serious radio okay
paul i just john oates is coming out
with a book awesome and the guy was
reading a segment you know at the end of
it 1980 or 1995
john hall or john oates had sold 80
million albums and he had 55 dollars in
the bank no way
because he didn't get any of the writing
credits just they were just saying the
story that just flew over my head legal
battles yeah yeah you know i was
watching sunday i was watching black
sabbath it was on real tv or real
whatever it is
and they told the whole story about
sabbath how they had made four albums
they all had gone platinum and they were
[ __ ] broke so they had to sue their
manager and then they counter suit and
they won
so they had to go on a five-week
japanese run
three nights four nights a week just to
[ __ ] break even to pay the attorneys
back yeah
like that [ __ ] is a [ __ ] nightmare
stones did that they owed so much in
taxes that's why it's called exile
right now i know about that stuff but
it's just
i do not understand how
those contracts work with music i had
danny brown in here and i asked him a
little bit and i got it yeah and i want
like i tried to get don felder in here
but he said he's not taking interviews i
really want to get to the nuts and bolts
of some how this happens
in 19 i mean were you just doing that
many [ __ ] drugs
no it's just back in the day like
especially in the 60s and 70s the the
the
the precipice or the
you know the beginning of like oh this
guy gave me a deal and now i'm a
millionaire
but some guys you know
for as many of those guys that there
were there were probably eight guys that
got deals
that weren't great
like and that and that went on until the
90s like the cro black crow's first deal
was [ __ ]
and they actually the only reason they
got out of it was because deaf american
was so poorly staffed that they didn't
watch their options and they [ __ ] let
it lapse and so
the crows got to renegotiate but chuck
berry
all those cats like a guy a white dude
in a suit in 1968 comes up to you with a
piece of paper going i'll give you seven
thousand dollars right now if you sign
this
you go [ __ ] yeah and you don't read it
and then you realize that he just took
99 of your publishing
and that's where all the money is
whatever the jewish guy from the
sopranos
yeah yeah
you know
most musicians aren't lawyers
so even if they read the contract they
don't even know what the [ __ ] it says
and they don't know the difference
between the the one party and the other
party so the guy can totally tell him
yeah you're that guy with the 99 percent
and then when it comes to lawsuit time
he's like i never said that
i i just don't understand how you go on
the road
you have hit [ __ ] music
a million copies if you get a dollar an
album you're a [ __ ] millionaire
you're telling me that you don't get a
dollar they don't they get like seven
cents
oh
my
god now what if they own the music
that's where the money is that's where
the money is but that's you know that's
something you get at the end like maybe
now like you know jay-z saw the saw the
business in enough
forefront to be like i own my music and
he had his own you know he started
rockefeller from the start and it was
his
but you know you saw ray
like he didn't own his masters until
he kind of
made his he made them give him his
masters he just
kind of negotiated his way into that but
[ __ ] chuck berry
the ban i mean look at the band like
robbie robertson took all their money
and [ __ ]
two of them ended up or at least one of
them killed themselves richard manuel
killed himself at the end of the day
and you know because he had no money
whatsoever meanwhile robbie robertson's
got nine houses
you know sometimes it's not the manager
it's another dude in the band i know
that uh what's his name did that also uh
now i forget his [ __ ] name well that
happened with easy
yeah yeah if he watched fresh out of
compton him and then the manager was
robbing him
yeah he was robbing the band and the
manager was robbing him i just
it's such a [ __ ] day it would drive
me crazy dude that [ __ ] drives me
[ __ ] crazy
at the end of the day like you you show
a guy that's never seen eight grand in
his life you just give him eight grand
he's probably gonna sign whatever the
[ __ ] you put in front of me what the
[ __ ] are you kidding i got a call from
the ice house once when i was struggling
i was eating [ __ ] beans with my wife
and they called and said these guys want
to do a tape they're going to sell it to
naval bases and army bases in the war
you get 1500 flat 50 of the profits let
me tell you something that 1500 check
cash and i never saw those people again
yeah i was [ __ ] you know i wasn't i
didn't play at the ice house for two or
three years because i went off on the
owner you're responsible for it
you connected this with us that's like a
drug deal yeah you connect me with a bad
drug deal you cover for it brother and
he was like i'm not doing it so i called
an attorney
i got an attorney to look into the
company they had so many shell companies
and i would see soldiers at shows and
they'd bring me the dvds and i'd sign
and go
how many of these [ __ ] dvds were over
there he goes guys it was like suing the
predator because they the company would
just put stand up
comedy at the bases or something like
this and he goes this was the most
popular one for like three or four
months i knew for a fact they sold a ton
of them yeah yeah we never got a dime
and after that
before i do anything higher level let me
let me run this by my lawyer absolutely
even the [ __ ] and this is the problem
you have in l.a okay that a lot of
people don't know it's like
you have to go what time is your
reservation oh well i mean
i don't we didn't really have one okay
but we've been having so much fun at
times passed by the koreans stay open
all night they're drinking beer they're
playing dominoes
i should probably go in the next 15
years yeah let's get out of here but no
it's it's really interesting how lucky
we are that we don't
but in l.a you gotta watch it because
here's the problem
when i did my [ __ ]
deal
i took it to
the attorney where everybody takes it to
comedians yeah yeah and my wife read it
my wife's like you know what
this is a for gay these guys know each
other yeah yeah so my wife sent it to a
[ __ ] evil jew downtown that runs the
disney hall you know disney don't [ __ ]
with you unless you're jewish direct
roots [ __ ] hitler sent him to eisner
yeah these [ __ ] are mean yeah
yeah this [ __ ] came back
and just scratched half that contract up
and she goes tell joey nay
you see this little claws right there
that's how they get you yeah i mean we
got it to the point where we could
contact new wave and look at what they
invested like we have it we signed it
before i don't do it because you know
you're going to get robbed anyway yeah
you've been going through these deals
with these people you're like you know
but how much can they rob me absolutely
at the end of the day yeah if the pro if
the content gets out
they're going to see it at the end
miles davis always said albums are just
advertisements for the gigs that's it
that's what they really [ __ ] know
yeah
chris port i'm really happy you came on
you're one of the guys that uh
are the real guys you're one of the good
guys i appreciate it i feel the same you
gotta get out there more you gotta come
on here more dude i'll be out here i'll
come by anytime i love you to death
always so when i saw this minneapolis
thing oh that's it
when i go back i gotta hunt down chris
[ __ ] porter anything all right you
have any questions
you're cool everything was all right
when he contacted me because you mind my
girlfriend comes i thought it was gonna
be one of these things where i ask a
question he looks at you and you like
and then he looks back at me and goes i
can't answer that question i can't have
that [ __ ] that happened one time nah the
truth has been a lot around a lot longer
than she has so we gotta
[ __ ] get out where are you at the
next few weeks let me promote something
well
tomorrow and wednesday i'm in hermosa
comedy magic this weekend i'm at
stand-up scottsdale and next weekend
punchline in atlanta you got a website
chrisporter is funny.com but i'm getting
ready to relaunch it okay listen this is
one of my personal favorites
if he comes to your town give him the
respect go down and give him a hug
tell him i heard you on the church and
that's basically it what's going on with
you lee
i'm doing i'm doing good i'm like
excited to go to vegas and that's uh
that's it that's it you're just excited
to go to vegas
[ __ ] amazing wait till i get the
report from vegas
it never ends you know i'm saying it
never [ __ ] ends always on it
for supplements i love them to death
that hemp protein i live by it every
morning
that's what i drink for breakfast i mix
it around but honor is my favorite go to
honey.com right now and press in church
c-h-u-r-c-h
and get 10 off your first order also
let me tell you something are you hiring
do you know where to post your job to
find the best candidates
posting your job in one place isn't
enough to find quality candidates if you
want to find the perfect high you need
to post your job on all the top job
sites and now you can
with ziprecruiter.com you can post your
job to 200 plus job sites including
social media networks like facebook and
twitter all in one single click first
candidates in any city or industry
nationwide
find candidates in any city or any
industry nationwide just post once and
watch your qualified candidates roll
into zip recruiters easy to use
interface no juggling emails or calls to
your office quickly screen candidates
rate them and hire the right person fast
find out today why zip recruiter has
been used by fortune 100 companies
fortune 1000 i don't know 100 thousands
of small and medium-sized businesses and
right now my listeners can post jobs
because
ziprecruiter.com
church again that's ziprecruiter.com
church one more time for a free go
ziprecruiter.com
slash church if you're looking zip
recruit will do it for you number two
you're sleeping on a mattress you wake
up every morning you got headaches
your feet [ __ ] hurt in the morning
you know why because you're sleeping on
the wrong matches all that's changed
you're unique you don't walk like
everyone you don't talk like everyone
you don't sleep like everyone so why is
your mattress one size fits all why
because the customer mattress of course
cost you five to ten thousand bucks
until now introducing helix sleep where
you can buy mattresses online customized
for hundreds of dollars instead of
thousands go to helix
helixsleep.com
answer a few simple questions based on
four key preferences and the result will
be a custom sleep profile used to build
you a beautiful
most comfortable mattress you'll ever
sleep on your mattress will arrive at
your door in about a week and shipping
is 100
free free free and for couples helix
customizes each side of the mattress
helix customers report a 30 improvement
in overall sleep quality you have a
hundred nights to try it out and if you
don't love it they'll pick it up for
free and give you a hundred percent
refund no questions asked that's why
everyone from gq magazine the four is
all talking about helix sleep go to
helix.com joey and get 50 off your order
again
go to helix
dot com slash joey helix sleep.com joey
and get 50 off your order that's
helixsleep.com
joey
get some great sleep i want to thank
helix i want to thank zip recruiter
and i also want to thank anik for being
the best sponsors in the world i want to
thank my man
chris porter in the house
for coming on this hot night you could
open that door i'm sweating like [ __ ]
two [ __ ] at the parade you know what
i'm saying
getting a lot of work done i love you
[ __ ] stay black see you next
week have a great weekend see you in
baltimore maryland stay black babies
whoo yeah we're gonna turn the air or
i'll get an air conditioner inhaling
that's it i've had
but i just can't quite
assistant
oh
uh
please
i had to measure
oh
please tonight
baby
you